gerhard schröder feiert geburtstag in
der westlichsten stadt russlands
hannover wohin alle lieben und verehren
gerhard schröder hält von hannover ja
also nicht nicht doch doch dann ja was
denn die hits der war der beste hat doch
uns in den renten lüge steckt ja ich
meine sich als sozialdemokrat auszugeben
und dann im prinzip die komplette
sozialdemokratie oder die kompletten
sozialstaat zu integrieren und das find
ich schon nicht so cool
gewiss eher kritischer eingestellt ne ja
kritisch wenn ich das jetzt nicht nennen
ich finde ich schon ziemlich kacke
richtig geil dagegen ist die gästeliste
seiner geburtstagsparty im rathaus
lauter hallo war anna b promis die auch
vormittags zeit haben
er ist ein toller mann gerhard schröder
muss man sagen er hat viel getan für
dieses land
zum beispiel dass eine leiche oder fünf
mal fünf mal geheiratet keine kinder ist
eine tonne co2 bilanz oder ist doch
wunderbar schönen tag hallo
nichts kann also ich hab sie nicht
angefasst also ich in den wirtschaftlich
auf jeden fall den besten kanzlerin
gehabt haben er hat die spd von ihrem
sozialistischen image befreit kann man
sagen er hat europas größten
niedriglohnsektor erschaffen auch sagen
top also wenn die spd ihn gefolgt wäre
und in der mitte auf gemacht hätte wenn
sie woanders heute glaube ich also noch
weiter unten oder oben oben ganz oben
auch ein guter freund von gerd schröder
naja das war mein kulinarisch guter
freund sie das mit und vielleicht ein
glas wein vielleicht der 42
wie viel hat er einen sohn meistens
getrunken 22
ja wir sind jetzt hier im inner circle
vom hannoveraner rathaus oder wie es bei
gerhard schröder heißt in der duma und
erfrischend billig nörgler von der spd
hier also es könnte durchaus noch eine
schöne party werden herr oppermann
endlich mal ein tag ohne andrea nahles
oder glauben sie heute weniger bock
drauf heute schröder oder nadeln
ich finde gerd schröder hat doch diesen
tag erkennbar genossen und er hat es
auch verdient sie sind sie ein guter
freund auch ich bin von der fdp der
fraktionsvorsitzende
ich habe gute nachrichten sind mehr
freunde von der fdp als von der spd
heute da das kann sich vorstellen könnte
sie vielleicht noch ein paar
glückwünsche in die kamera sagen für
schröder auf russisch sie können ja
russischen keine rote schleifen sie
können kein russisch weil ich dachte
weil deutsche die so schlecht englisch
reden hatten ja oft russisch als erste
fremdsprache kapelle teil ist erst
kämpfen gehabt denn französisch dann
englisch aber kein russisch und sie ich
kann gar nichts dachte der herr kind zdf
und wenn sie sich die fragen selber
aussuchen dürfen auch dann nicht
[Musik]
ja schon hier sind auch gerhard schröder
als ex warum gekommen und sie sind in
gesprächen und mit diesem hoch
emotionalen bildern gebe ich zurück ins
studio
[Musik]
klickt hier für weitere heute schon
videos und klickt im moment
und klickt hier um den channel zu
abonnieren
[Musik]